certains avaient réservé leur place
depuis 9h ce matin
alors forcément l'ambiance est un peu
chaude c'est le dernier tour de piste
des étoiles de ce 51ème festival de
cannes
emmanuelle béart en dentelle
nikita pariot au bras de bernard
giraudeau gong li et andie macdowell
défilent robe est obligatoire pour tout
pour tout et même pour certains peter
mullan brigue le prix d'interprétation
dans le film de ken loach my name is joe
lavier vraiment belle pour le
réalisateur italien roberto benigni
un vrai rêve pour ses deux anges elodie
bouchez et natacha régnier jeune
comédienne qui ont séduit les
festivaliers et peut-être le jury le
réalisateur grec theo angelopoulos rêve
d'éternité
une palme d'or suffirait à son bonheur
jean reno lui n'a pas ces angoisses
il est venu pour s'amuser avec le dis là
le film présenté ce soir peinture